in 2012 the SEIU launched an all-out
effort to unionize the fast-food
industry including some 800,000
McDonald's workers it's been three years
and there's been lots of organizing but
the effort is still very far from
winning union recognition anywhere let's
look at the largest chain of hamburger
fast-food restaurants McDonald's
McDonald's uses a franchise structure
meaning that of its 800,000 employees
only around 90,000 technically worked
for the McDonald's Corporation under
current law the other 700 10,000 are
employed by one of the 3,100 McDonald's
franchise owners in the US for the SEIU
to organized the majority of McDonald's
workers the old-fashioned way it would
have to go franchise to franchise
overcoming opposition and negotiating
separate contracts with each franchisee
a process too arduous and inefficient to
make sense
SEIU has successfully gotten around
these kinds of who's the boss issues in
the past in both the janitorial and
security industries essentially the
Union pressured the lead company to
allow unionization of a company that
works for them but reaching a similar
agreement with McDonald's is much more
difficult legally McDonald's can't just
command all of its franchisees to
negotiate with a union however it could
put language in its future franchise
agreements that require the franchises
to negotiate with unions if the union's
can show the employees want union
representation this would make it much
easier to win bargaining with lots of
franchisees who could then choose to
negotiate as a group
McDonald's corporation could also help
the franchisees cover the higher costs
of unionized workers or it could agree
to be treated as a joint employer along
with the franchisees that could be
enough to bring the union the franchisee
is and the corporation all to the
bargaining table but what makes this
unlikely as something simple McDonald's
just doesn't want a union telling it
you